[Music]
[Applause]
you look wonderful oh my God I love
coming back this is where I used to have
my talk show me lately so every time I
come back and hear some of the beard
some of the people are still here left
over oh yeah so I get to see some of the
people that worked on my show and then I
come in I'm here for 20 minutes but I
get to leave right yeah yeah but um so
you just got back from Mallorca I went
to my Orca for a month with a bunch of
my oh you haven't you have to come I
have a house there you do yes and it's
and it is one of the most beautiful
places in the world Mallorca we went on
crazy we did a lot of exercising a
little too much exercising for my and
for my own uh interests actually but you
we drink a lot of sangria and then we
get on our bikes and we bike it off so
it kind of adds up like it makes sense
so that you can get away with it you
know what I'm saying yep um but like two
weeks into the vacation my friends were
like are we at a fat camp like what is
going on here this hap so I went on a
like a fun beach like whatever
destination and all this sudden I they
were like we're gonna go on this
beautiful hike in the mountains and I
was like this is like literally it was
hell and I don't want to do this on
vacation I was miserable going all the
way up and then you get up there like I
could have just bought a postcard okay
wait so we just passed something that
you celebrate I've never heard of this
it's is it fat bear week fat bear week
well I love bear week well a fat bear I
think there's a fat bear day where they
ju or is it a week oh it should be they
get the biggest fattest black and brown
bears and they compare their bodies and
I love big fat animals like my dogs are
slightly obese because I like them that
way okay and I like to get dogs that are
heavier even if it's bad for their hips
I'll just make my house wheelchair
accessible
you know what I mean because the more
meat I just like to get into bed after a
long day and just put a big fat furry
animal on top of me and rub my face and
then when it gets too hot I can just say
get the hell off of me you know what I
mean not a dude that's what I'm looking
for in a companion
it's my dog oh yeah and lays right here
and thinks he's a small dog but not very
heavy so I hear you're also celebrating
the end of flip-flop season oh so oh
yeah I have a problem with men and
flip-flops oh I have a problem with
flip-flops oh wow high five yeah finally
I um don't appreciate anything between
my toes oh oh you have a problem with
her I have a problem with other people
wearing flip-flops I don't care what you
want to do with your toes but mine shall
never have anything in in them I feel
like I I understand what you're saying
and I respect that I also don't like
things in between my toes but I I don't
I think there's a season for flip-flops
and that's called summertime and you
should be by you know an ocean or a
beach or a water feature when you're
wearing them especially if you're a
straight man who doesn't get pedicures
or take care of your feet I don't like
when men push flip-flops into other
seasons and try and get away with that
those are shoes yeah those are for us
and gay men people who take care of
their shoes and feet sorry take care of
their feet I can't it's also not a shoe
it's just like a it's like a flop you
know you're not supporting yourself or
protecting yourself from all the gross
things
you're all coming like you can hear
people coming from a mile away yeah
because of the the flip and the Flop
like you can yeah anyway just say okay
so it's throwback Thursday here you are
as a young woman I love this photo it's
amazing I had no idea you're a beauty
queen like it wow you are this is
amazing you are so beautiful and I
didn't know because your personality you
just read like you would be the one to
make fun maybe or poke fun at the beach
exactly so this is that you you that by
the way I was 14 years old in that
picture you're 14 in that picture and I
look like I'm 65. well I look like I'm
45. you look 19. well I look like The
Lion King is what I look like
yeah I was from New Jersey so that was
what you did every morning you got up
and made your hair into a right angle
um yeah so I was in like two beauty
pageants and then uh then I found out
you had to have a talent and I was like
you know what am I gonna do I can't
really dance and I can't play an
instrument does anybody do a stand-up
does anybody not no no no no it's not
really I mean not when you're 14. that
would have been a good one but you get
like three minutes to show off some
talent and once I found that out I was
like oh I'll just become a model and
then that failed miserably so I became a
stand-up comedian
I just thought I saw that I was like oh
my gosh this is crazy it's beautiful the
dresses thank you yeah thank you yeah
and in pageants in the state of New
Jersey growing up or something that
people take very seriously I'm also in
Texas yes
so how is the vaccinated and horny tour
going
um any favorite moments uh well I just
filmed my special in Nashville which is
the best at the Ryman you know oh my God
I love it yeah
[Applause]
um and it looks really beautiful and
these are my last 20 dates if you go to
chelseahandler.com I am finishing up my
tour for the year so I'm finishing off
I'm going to all the smaller cities that
I haven't been to yet yeah um and yeah
it's been great to be on the road I mean
it's great to be able to walk into a you
know an audience filled with thousands
of people and bring them together some
for the very first times and make them
laugh you know remind people about
togetherness and forget about the world
that we're living in for an hour and a
half it's a nice treat to be able to
give that it is cool when you look out
and you're like because at comedy shows
I'll find the student Musical shows too
you're like where would all these people
be in a bill at the same time you know
I'm saying it's a random you know Motley
Crew of people it's cool yeah I had a
woman at my show this weekend I was in
Niagara Falls and she was and I started
talking to her in the front row and I
realized she was like this a 79 year old
woman who had taken a bus in from a town
called pinkering uh which was like hours
away and she comes to this casino
and she goes and she's like I lost my
husband a year ago and I just come out
and take the bus every few weeks to see
comedy and I gave her my hotel room
because I wasn't staying there and the
Niagara Falls is lit up at night and so
it's a beautiful view and I was talking
to her before I knew her husband died I
was like husband had died I was like oh
my God take my room you don't have to
take the bus home tonight stay here
gamble hook up you know go back to my
room and she was like this little old
lady she had size four and a half shoes
I noticed those right away because they
were you know a little bite-sized I was
like I like that too
and when she came backstage she's like
oh she told me the story about her
husband I'm like oh my God I'm so sorry
I told you to hook up she's like no I
might actually hook up thank you so that
was cute that was a nice treat she
probably had no idea who she was coming
to see so but you forget though how
beautiful that is like that's awesome
that like maybe there's like some kind
of Darkness that's happened in her life
and it's her moment to like Escape
that's cool
it made me feel good yeah yeah I like
her I hope she had a good time
um so was there a moment that you knew
you were meant to do stand up like when
you were young
you know I would just always go off on
people and I would like I feel like
Julia sugar Baker on Designing Women I
just was always arguing with people in
school like not not other students but
people in positions of authority you
know like I would always just everyone
would just annoy me I'm like why does
this guy get to tell me what to do
because I'm eight you know this is like
I don't like this Paradigm and um and so
when I got older and I moved to LA I
didn't really know what I was gonna do I
thought I'd become an actress or
something and then I would read other
people's lines and I wasn't very good at
at reading other things that people had
written like I wanted to write my own
material and then somebody suggested it
they were like you should do a Stan you
should do stand-up and I was like huh
I'm like me on stage with a microphone
and nobody else is allowed to talk I'm
like that's exactly what I should do
this is my calling that sounds like a
plan I could get behind but I was so
scared you know because getting up on
stage in front of everybody as you know
is scary and talking as care scary so it
took a while I mean you got a lot of
diarrhea I mean that's what happened and
I'm telling you there's another big
difference of what you just said like
because people are like you sing in
front of people all the time like why
because sometimes I I don't ever get
nervous doing this or like talking like
this but when they ask me like present
or like do something like that or have
to talk in it I'm literally my stomach
is just like like it's just like what
because it's so different because with
music I feel like there's Melody there's
you're locked into like a a like a
formula of what's happening and you're
just out there on your own like your own
timing the crowd's different they laugh
at different things you know I'm saying
you're feeding off different energy
that's way harder yeah it is it is but
once you get good at it and once you
have an audience and fans that are so
loyal and come to see you it's like it's
just so it becomes this cathartic it's
just awesome it's awesome to get out
there and just like destroy it you know
like go out there and express yourself
yeah and get a standing ovation and it's
good and just watching people's
reactions to the crazy things that come
out of your mouth you're watching people
go oh my God you know like it gives me
joy to bring that emotion to people I
love that it still does that yeah I know
I know sometimes it you know sometimes
it doesn't and sometimes you have to
bring back the joy in in the performance
me too so you know you have to get be in
your Flow State yeah so you always have
to remember that you're performing for
your audience not for yourself yeah amen
you have had a lot of therapy tonight
um it's nice it's breast cancer
awareness month I know that you lost
your mama to breast cancer so what's
something that she taught you that stays
with you
um well uh what she told me to always
wear my seatbelt so I always do that
even when I don't feel like I should or
that I don't need to I always wear my
seatbelt but I did get my mammogram the
other day for yeah because Katie Couric
and I she said would you post about uh
you know breast cancer awareness and I
said of course and then I went and got
my mammogram and I was just thinking
like what do people do like because men
have to get tested for breast cancer as
well and what do men do in those
machines that trap you like that when
they don't have any breast tissue to put
in there you know so what does it
squeeze I I don't know but it must be so
painful you know to put I mean I don't
really know where I'm going with this
story but I'll tell you like people kind
of scared me about getting a mammogram
and I've had a couple of them and I
don't feel I don't it it didn't bother
me but I mean I guess I have a boob so
it might hurt if you don't have a boob
yeah I mean I have very large breasts
and it hurts badly I don't okay well
that is just a really good okay amount
and it's real it served me well yeah and
mammograms yeah yeah yeah because it's
not it's not that unpleasant it's
bearable no my sister's like it is a
good word for it yeah I would describe
it it's so smart though because people
are women are getting younger and
younger yeah you have to always take
care of yourself and get you have to get
breast exams and you have to get
colonoscopies at the age of 45. and they
both don't sound appealing and they're
not but it's just good to get ahead and
have information about anything that
might go wrong you know in your health
world you want to be ahead of it of
course knowledge is power yep
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]